I said about a month ago that we have to
keep focusing on what's happening in the
courts and I'm going to do that today
yesterday Donald Trump was impeached
that was important that was the correct
outcome based on the facts but again
Republicans in the Senate pushed through
11 more judges in the Senate if we think
about the future of this country there
are many important things immigration
policy health care policy who is the
President of the United States who is on
the Supreme Court but much more quietly
Republicans are being smart and they are
setting themselves up for a massive
rightward move in the judiciary for
decades with the judges that they are
pushing through with very few
comparatively people noticing that
they're doing it Mitch McConnell has
successfully pushed through a record 50
appellate court judges remember most
cases never make the Supreme Court
they're decided at lower levels that's
why this is so important plus of course
we know about Donald Trump's two Supreme
Court picks Neal Gorsuch and Brett
kavanah one of which should have been
Obama's pick of Merrick garland remember
every two hours yesterday the Senate was
voting on a judge and pushing through
these Trump nominees they have been
sickeningly efficient and it doesn't get
the media attention that it deserves but
I've been making the effort to talk
about it and I'm going to continue
eleven nominees in August of 2018 15
nominees in October of 2018 and on and
on and on through Donald Trump's
presidency now as I've told you before
at different court levels many of Donald
Trump's picks have been rated not
qualified by the American Bar
Association these are people who have no
business being judges they are blindly
partisan political actors who don't even
qualify on the basis of the American Bar
Association and some of these are
lifetime appointments and these people
will get to make law via their decisions
for a very very long time and in fact
Mitch McConnell isn't stupid and he at
least must be thinking a 2020 bloodbath
is possible for Republicans they could
lose the house they could have an even
bigger deficit in terms of the house
split
balance of power they could lose the
White House they could lose the Senate
although they are likely to keep it
they might not though there is no better
insurance policy politically than
packing any court that you can with as
many of your people as possible
particularly blindly partisan actors and
that is exactly what they are doing
Mitch McConnell is a bad faith actor
he's truly a scourge in the American
political system and he has been for a
long time but this guy knows how to
operate I've said this before I hate the
guy in terms of his politics but the
obstruction he pulled off during the
Obama administration headlined of course
by denying Barack Obama a Supreme Court
seat that should have been his should
have been Merrick Garland's seat that
was put on hold held it so that Donald
Trump ultimately got to choose a
replacement stuffing the courts at all
levels with their judges it could take a
generation to rebalance courts from what
Mitch Mitch McConnell did so love him or
hate him and I'm disgusted with him it's
undeniable that he has quietly been one
of the most effective Senate Majority
Leader's in modern American politics and
quite frankly this is one reason that
Republicans keep tolerating Trump it's
not all about this but under the cover
of public trump scandal and impeachment
and all of this other embarrassment
internationally the donald trump engages
in getting dozens and dozens of judges
through into a lot of lifetime positions
is an unconscionable political win the
tax windfalls for some people who
support Trump certainly didn't help but
this is Republicans winning for thirty
to forty years with the influence that
some of these judges are going to have
this is a red-alert setback for the
country unqualified activist judges who
have no idea what's going on will
butcher and will mold the law like putty
to fit their right-wing worldview often
informed by religion sometimes just
informed by reactionary politics this is
an argument for many things it's an
argument for term limits for judges yes
it's also an argument for we need to be
able to focus on more than one thing at
a time and we need to force corporate
media to do so as well and
really really important and I say this
because we're heading we are almost in
an election year once again we need to
immediately throw in the trash talking
points like those that were parodied by
some on the left in 2016 like if it's
not X I don't care between Hillary and
Trump it's sort of all the same just on
the issue of judges alone you could not
be more wrong forget about any other
aspect of it we really need to get back
to the drawing board on that because the
right is crushing us on this issue much
like they've been crushing us at the
local level in many ways much like
they've been crushing us on properly
funding young activists coming out of
college to become conservative leaders
that the left doesn't do this even
though you know we we do have money
conceivably money is out there but it's
not used in this particular way they're
crushing us in a lot of places and we're
only doubling down on the damage that
they do when we say stuff like and
Hillary Trump sort of all the same the
judges confirm it is not big ly big ly
confirm that before you go on to the
next video please hit subscribe and like
we are trying to figure out what this
will do for helping us in YouTube's
algorithm I will report back to you but
please before you go on to the next
video please subscribe to our channel
and hit that like button thank you